music in the air
and I really do believe
I really do believe
there's a Heaven somewhere.
Up above my head
up above my head
I hear singin' in the air
singin' in the air.
Up above my head
up above my head
I hear singin' in the air
I hear singin' in the air.
Up above my head
up above my head
I hear singin' in the air
singin' in the air
and I really do believe
I really do believe
there's a Heaven somewhere.
(Speaks) All right now, guitar man!
(Guitar music)
That's Hubby Jenkins, y'all.
(Sings) Up above my head
up above my head
I hear shoutin' in the air
shoutin' in the air.
Up above my head
up above my head
I hear shoutin' in the air
I hear shoutin' in the air.
Up above my head
up above my head
I hear shoutin' in the air, that's right,
and I really do believe I really do believe
there's a heaven somewhere.
(Speaks) All right now, give me some of that bass.
(Bass solo)
Yeah!
Woo!
Jason Sypher on the bass.
Jamie Dick on those drums.
All right now,
I'm running out of time.
So it's time for y'all to sing.
This is the call-and-response.
I call, you respond.
There are so many songs like this, y'all know how it goes, don't you?
You're going to sing along?
I said, are you going to sing along?
Audience members: Yes!
Rhiannon Giddens: Here we go!
(Sings) Up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: music in the air
AM: music in the air.
RG: up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: music in the air
AM: music in the air
RG: up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: music in the air
AM: music in the air
RG: and I really do believe I really do believe
there's a heaven somewhere.
One more time!
Up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: I hear music in the air
AM: music in the air.
RG: Up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: I hear music in the air
AM: music in the air.
RG: Up above my head
AM: up above my head
RG: I hear music in the air
AM: music in the air
RG: and I really do believe I really do believe
there's a heaven somewhere.
I said I really do believe I really do believe
Heaven somewhere.
(Holds note)
(Applause and cheers)
(Music ends)
(Applause)